season two of the HBO series true
detective just ended this past weekend
now I don't even following this thing
but critics hated it and viewers stayed
away in droves
now of course season 1 of true detective
was such a huge hit
afterwards Matthew McConaughey was
picked to be the new spokesman for
Lincoln cars just because he was you
have so much excitement about him well
season 2 star Colin Farrell is not
faring as well check out the new ad he
was just hired to make there are times
you're moving forward when all you want
to do is drive back times when your life
takes a wrong turn you can't see the
road ahead but the road behind you looks
pretty good you can't always fill the
shoes that were left behind did I let
them talk me into this my bologna has a
first name let's say char
[Music]
introducing the 2015 Oscar Mayer
Wienermobile
[Applause]
I'm just excited that Wienermobile czar
available to ya you know what I heard
we're buying tomorrow yeah I mean you're
lucky to keep me through the rest of the
show wasn't that a great clip subscribe
to my youtube channel for an endless
supply of me
[Laughter]